the Cloverfield movie verse has now
officially expanded into some wild new
territory
Netflix surprised fans of the sci-fi
film series by dropping the third
installments the Cloverfield paradox on
Superbowl Sunday without warning like
the first two films Cloverfield three
offers a new perspective on why all
those giant monsters have appeared on
earth if you haven't seen it yet you
might want to click away now because
we're about to take a deep dive into
outer space still with us
good the film centers on an
International Space Station crew who are
tasked with trying to solve the world's
ongoing energy crisis by testing a
particle accelerator known as the
Sheppard the mission is critical as
widespread starvation and world was
threatened to break out on earth the
crews miracle machine launch doesn't
quite go as planned though as it sends a
whole ship to another dimension so how
does the film tie everything together
and what Easter eggs can be found
floating throughout the space module
let's take a look the obligatory Calvin
nod as the biggest named producer of all
three films JJ Abrams was free to
sprinkle in terms of in references to
his own life and previous works fans of
Abrams may recognize the name of the gas
station that Ava Hamilton and her
husband Michael are waiting on line 4 at
the beginning of the movie it's called
Kelvin which is a brand that's appeared
in a ton of Abrams prior projects it was
a name of the man who occupied the hatch
in lust it was the name of a spaceship
in Star Trek and even Star Wars The
Force awakens included a place called
Kelvin Ridge the name is a nod to
Abraham's grandfather Henry Kelvin who
was very influential to his interest in
movies the Kelvin gas station logo
previously appeared in a scene from 10
Cloverfield Lane so it also makes sense
to include it here for continuity sake
and that's not the only bit of brand
loyalty Abrams snuck into the pick
either the slusho connection
another common thread found in most JJ
Abrams projects is slusho a fictional
brand of ice drinks that seems to pop up
everywhere in abrams universe from his
hit small screen series alias and fringe
to Star Trek it also appears in the
first Cloverfield film Jason Hawkins
sports a shirt with the logo as a homage
to his brother Rob's nude gig with the
company but their hand in the havoc that
levels the planet might be heavier than
fans anticipated according to the in
universe law the brand is
owned by a Japanese mining company
called terrazzo which is heavily
featured in the Cloverfield alternate
reality game and is said to have set up
offshore oil rigs throughout the world
the company name is also listed on a
letter sent to Howard Stambler in 10
Cloverfield Lane which led some Easter
egg hunts us to believe their drilling
platforms might have opened up some kind
of conduit for the original monsters to
emerge through digital materials later
revealed during the run-up for 10
Cloverfield Lane offered details of
stumblers job working with satellites
and the company's satellite launch which
detail-oriented fans suspected had gone
south and opened up the floodgates of
monsters however the events of the
Cloverfield paradox seemed to challenge
the long-held notion that a satellite
failure started this whole thing
alternatively the presence of a slasher
bobblehead doll in the spaceship along
with a sighting of the actual company
logo on board suggests that tiger art
show has also been funding the Shepard
project so that means yes they're still
totally responsible for all of this just
not in the way people thought in the
last shot of Cloverfield the original
movie there appears to be a falling
something perhaps that's the escape pod
scene at the end of the Cloverfield
paradox a brotherly bond another common
thread the Cloverfield paradox weaves
with the previous sequel is the last
name of another conspiracy theorist
showcase in the movie marks tumblr yes
Stambler is the last name of John
Goodman's character in 10 Cloverfield
Lane and t2 seems to have some advanced
knowledge of the Hellfire that would
rain down on earth marks tumblr has seen
giving a news interview about his book
which shares a title with this movie and
promoting his Twitter handle paradox is
real which is also real opiate inactive
some suspect the two characters might be
related or even brothers as it's
certainly no coincidence they are
equally impassioned about their beliefs
in his end of days events howard
stumblers bunker guest slash prisoner
Emmet even makes fun of him in 10
Cloverfield Lane by poking fun at his
theory about mutant space worms but jug
becomes all too real in paradox when our
Russian comrade Volkov gets eaten from
the inside out
after the ship's earthworms are
teleported into his body during the
accidental dimensional hop a familiar
face
if the connection between the stumbleth
wasn't clear enough as an even closer
connection drawn between them by way of
actress Suzanne Cryer in the Cloverfield
paradox she portrays a broadcast
journalist who's seen interviewing marks
tumblr and if she looks familiar
there's a reason she also appears
briefly in 10 Cloverfield Lane as the
injured woman who's desperately trying
to gain entry into Howard's Tumblr's
bunker you clarify you believe their
efforts to solve the energy crisis might
unleash demons too bad she didn't listen
to a special guest that day huh a mama
monster in unearthed production notes
for the first film JJ Abrams director
Matt Reeves and screenwriter Drew
Goddard talked about the theories and
themes that went into the film and
Abrams made an interesting comment about
the monster he's a baby he's brand new
he's confused disoriented and irritable
and he's been down there in the water
for thousands and thousands of years
given that clover could level the
skyscraper without even flexing it might
have been hard for fans to conceive of
this creature as anything even remotely
resembling a baby but the final shot of
the Cloverfield paradox makes up very
possible now whereas Cloverfield
Manhattan shredding Monster was as big
as any building on the island the
monster that's shown ripping through the
clouds in the final scene looks to be as
big as some small countries which means
they've ever opened another dimension of
craziness with that second Shepard
overload or clovers mother has come out
to play Nell too foreshadowing part 4
marks Tumblr's words drawing his on-air
interview should it be more harrowing to
everyone who watched especially those on
the space station
however they tuned him Alton got right
to the job of doing exactly what he was
warning against because in their minds
the mission of solving the world's
energy crisis was far more pressing than
reading his promoted book to see if he
was making any sense but one thing he
did say that in retrospect seems
important is how wide reaching the
interdimensional warps of the Sheppard
would be he told the reporter they were
ripping open the membrane of space-time
smashing together multiple dimensions
shattering reality in the past in the
future in other dimensions that
certainly gives the Cloverfield movie
universe a limited room to grow and
movie for Overlord is expected to center
on a world war 2 era encounter involving
American paratroopers and the Nazi
occupied village spam blurs suggestion
that the past could be affected by their
space flub seems like a clever way of
keeping the film in the Cloverfield
universe - despite hopping back in time
a few decades thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff for know your love to
[Music]